cities all over Germany searched homes
of last generation activists the climate
group is being accused of collecting one
and a half million dollars in donations
that police say could be used for
criminal acts
our website and our email have been
taken down and several technical devices
have been confiscated and accounts are
blocked it doesn't mean that the
resistance will stop
for weeks activists of last generation
have been blocking roads by gluing
themselves to the asphalt protesting
against what they call a lack of
government action in the fight against
global warming and this is how some have
responded
anyway
you won't
achieve global warming zero zero the
actions of last generation came under
intense criticism after medical
personnel could not get to patients in
time
now I can't take care of my patients
because they glue themselves my patients
are helplessly lying in bed and I can't
get to them
the people that are here on the streets
they sure don't like me I am aware of
that but the point is that we need to
talk about this problem the German
government is incapable of dealing with
this crisis so what we do with this with
this blockade is being the fire alarm
the interior Minister Justified The Raid
saying the activists have broken the law
by blocking the roads
I have always stressed that we can only
fight the climate crisis democratically
supporting our society is very important
for this in my view these protests are
damaging this
despite facing more and more aggression
these activists have failed to continue
their blockades and while some
authorities are looking into declaring
last generation a criminal organization
they are receiving some support from
society amid growing criticism against
the group churches have opened their
doors to last generation activists a
press conference responding to the
police rates was held in a church
we see that last generation is intensely
and courageously fighting for climate
Justice a goal we as a church fully
support we saw 250 000 people
participating in peaceful rallies in
Berlin and the government did nothing
now we see that the government is
criminalizing these activists as a
church we stand up and say no we will
stand by them if last generation is
declared a criminal organization its
members could face up to five years in
prison despite the risks they say they
will broaden their protests in the
coming weeks to other parts of the
country stepfast and Al Jazeera Berlin